So median filtering for
background subtraction does
exactly what you might think.
All right, now we're going to
assume that the background
will be modeled by the last end framed
but I'm not going to take the average.
I'm going to take the median value.
What's kind of nice about that is
now n can be kind of nice and long.
Let's suppose the average, let's
suppose when I look at the, the road.
Let's suppose its value is 57.
Plus or minus a little,
57, 58, 56, 52, 57, etc,.
Then comes along a white car.
[NOISE] And it's like got 112,
119, 194, fine.
Then comes along a black Porsche.
Slowly because he's being cool,
you know it's three and not.
But if you take a look
at all those values,
the one that's going to dominate is
going to be the 57 to 56 etc, so
when I do a median filter, that's
the one that's going to get pulled out.
So now your foreground mask is we
just take the current image and
we subtract that the median
of the last end frames, okay?
And again, threshold.
Your n by the way now is
a little less sensitive.
I mean it has to be big
enough to capture it.
There is, as you know, those of
you know about in your computing,
a running average is easy to compute.
You just have to know how many frames
you've, you've added into the average so
far and the previous average and
then it's 1 over n of the new 1
plus n minus 1 over n of the old 1.
A median,
you have to actually keep them.
And then resort them, and
that can be expensive.
So, unless you'd play some interesting
tricks, median filtering can be
expensive, but it, but it's,
it's not too much of a problem.
All right.
When you apply the median, well,
it turns out if you use short n,
it might not be quite so great.
So, for example, here we have
the estimated background and
you can see a lot of stuff has gotten
cleaned up, but because of the small
n I still get this problem in terms
of where the van is and you're
doing a better job getting the van but
you still get a little bit of the stuff